[Music]
last night on the show we did a sketch
about the new Star Trek film I remember
I remember okay and at the end of the
sketch we ran fake Star Trek credits
fake credits
well now the site comicbook.com is
claiming that we may have spoiled a
major plot point of the new movie in our
credits and they really go on and on
about it well I have to respond just to
clarify those credits that we ran were
completely fake okay we were not trying
to spoil anything guard this of what
that website says we don't work that
hard no yeah but I was surprised that
that website fixated on that particular
sketch okay because after all last
night's episode if you look at the whole
episode was packed with totally real
Star Trek spoilers really yeah if you
look closely at these clips from our
show last night see if you can catch any
tonight's episode in the new Star Trek
gets impregnated to the Klingon
what a great crowd we have tonight I
love that sign this woman held up a sign
that says Conan we chose you over
studying for finals are you doing this
Spock is dead
please welcome head of an iron and wine
[Music]
20 minutes in this a pivotal scene with
a enter grunts crashes on Tatooine he
meets up with the star was gang and
Captain Kirk and Princess Leia bang it's
a surprising twist nobody saw that
coming
[Applause]
[Music]
now that I think about it I remember all
of those now